All right, let's start today with a weekly
coronavirus update, it does seem increasingly
like what we said last week might be going on is
going on, which is that the plateau in the decline
in cases and deaths that we saw last week was not
really a plateau. It wasn't really a reversal.
It was an artifact of the storms in much
of the country which slowed down testing
and vaccination. I'll explain in more detail,
but let's just jump right into the numbers,
starting with cases. Of course, on January 11th,
we saw the average peak of daily cases hit 250000,
55000 cases per day, a number that a year
ago would have been inconceivable when Dr.
Fauci said we might get to 100000 cases a day.
So many people saying, no, we won't. And we got to
an average of two hundred and fifty five thousand
cases a day as of January 11th. But then we saw a
reverse and the numbers started to decline and
we saw an average case. Numbers go below 200000
a day, below 150000 a day, below 100000 a day,
down to about 70000 cases a day. And then around
February 19th, 20th, the decline appeared to stop.
Case numbers even went up a few days. Now, my idea
was this is not a real increase. This is because
of the bad weather in the United States. Why would
that be the storms that pushed Texas into blackout
conditions right around mid-February lead to lower
than actual numbers being reported for some
time. So the decline we saw in mid-February
was bigger than reality because a lot of testing
was being delayed. At the end of February, as
testing got caught up, we were getting more cases
reported than the real number of new cases as the
backlog tests were processed. So yesterday was
the day with the fewest cases since October 13th,
right around fifty two thousand cases. And I
believe that that's the real number. I think
there was a period between January 11th and
yesterday where numbers were artificially low
and then a period where numbers were artificially
high. I think that the backlog has been cleared.
And we're now back to sort of the real numbers.
One example, a friend of mine's dad
was tested around February 15th.
It took 11 days to get the results that he
tested positive. He's doing fine. He's actually
vaccinated and has no symptoms whatsoever.
That is a positive test that should have shown
up far earlier, but because of the delays that
didn't show up until February 28th. So bottom
line cases from the peak on January 11th, down
73 percent. That's a great number. We're closing
in on getting below 50000 a day. That would be
an important milestone. Now in terms of deaths,
a very similar trajectory. Deaths peaked at about
3400 today on January 26th from that point.
Deaths are down 42 percent.
We saw a similar bump, right as the storms
passed and the data normalized, there is no doubt
that 900 deaths a day, which is where we are now,
is outrageous. But if you have outrageous, tragic
numbers that are going down, you prefer that to
outrageous, tragic numbers that are going up.
Another important statistic that we track
our hospitalizations. Good news there is that
hospitalizations are down from a peak of more than
one hundred and thirty thousand just after the
start of twenty twenty one, down from one hundred
and thirty K to about 52000 hospitalizations.
That's a hospitalization
decline of about 60 percent.
As more and more high risk people get vaccinated,
that number should decline more. Now, the really
exciting news, if there's anything exciting
at all to look at in the midst of horrible
tragedy that's coming from vaccines, we now
have a third vaccine given in emergency use
authorization. This is the Johnson and Johnson
vaccine. It is a one dose vaccine. Now,
there are people who are negative on this vaccine
saying, oh, it's less efficacious than the fizer
and unmodern of vaccines. And there are three
important things to consider there. Number one,
the Johnson and Johnson vaccine, even if
less effective at preventing infections,
appears to be just as good as the other vaccines
at preventing serious covid and keeping people out
of hospitals. All right. So, number one, that's
a very important number to it's only one dose,
meaning that given X number of doses, if you have
five million JMJ doses, you can vaccinate five
million people rather than just 2.5 million if you
had that same number of Fizer or Moderna doses,
because it's one dose only. And number three, it's
not actually clear that the JMJ vaccine really is
not as good at preventing infection. Now,
I know the headlines are often Pfizer,
Moderna. Ninety five percent effective, JNJ
only 65, 70 percent. There are studies these are
still preprint. So take everything with with some
skepticism now. But there are studies that suggest
that because the JMJ Phase three trials were
tested on the variants that were so worried about,
including the South Africa variant, that the lower
number, the 65 70 percent, reflects the variance,
and that if you were to do the Pfizer and
Moderna trials with the variants, you would
also be seeing 65, 70 percent. So the point is,
it's not really clear JNJ is less effective,
get whatever vaccine is available. And we had
a very good three day period this past weekend,
Friday, Saturday, Sunday, where almost seven
million doses were injected over the three days,
six point nine million doses, in fact. So we are
now averaging one point eight million doses a day.
Joe Biden wanted to do a million a day for
100 days. We might be able to double that.
We might be able to more than double it.
We could even be getting to 2.5 or three
million doses a day regularly soon as there are
massive dumps of vaccine doses coming in March.
Realistically, it it's conceivable that
the problem by the end of this month
will be do we have enough vaccine vaccination
sites and vaccinators to inject all of the
doses that we're going to have? Some locations
probably need to start thinking about ramping up
to 24/7 vaccination. That's a good problem
to have, assuming you can solve it. We want
to make sure that we can use all of the doses
that we're getting. So things are looking up.
It's a race against the variance, it's a get
a race against people behaving less carefully
because of the good news, but I continue to be
cautiously optimistic. We'll check in again in
another week. Send me your thoughts about what's
going on locally with vaccines where you live.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
After the break, we are going to talk about
council culture. Yes, it's the right's new
obsession. Many requests for a sort of overview
about council culture as the
new pet issue for the right.
There's very specific reasons
why the right is focused on it.
You can also make sure you're following us
on Instagram at David Pakman show. For more
on all of these stories, we'll take a
quick break and be back with much more